tell us about flexible human networks in
the frontiers of meddler thank you so by
means of introduction I recently
finished my PhD at Berkeley and I'm
sorry as faculty at Stanford and what my
research was interested in is broadly
how can we enable agents to learn skills
in the real world and by the real world
I mean robots robots like these that can
learn how to use tools like spatulas
that can learn how to place objects and
play with toys and and learn from humans
and so you might ask well why why work
with robots machine learning and AI is
is pretty cool uh but robots seem like
they might be a lot of work and the
reason why I think robots are
interesting to study is because I think
that they can teach us things about
intelligence now you might think this is
rather silly because robots are not very
smart all right but I think that they
can teach us things about intelligence
because they're faced with all the
challenges that humans are faced when
they're learning in the real world
they're faced with objects in the real
world that they must generalize across
tasks across objects across environments
in order to be successful they need to
be able to have some sort of common
sense understanding in order to do well
in a variety of different situations and
supervision can't really be taken for
granted as in a lot of machine learning
settings so I I think that if we can
solve important problems in robotics and
actually enable robots to do things in
the real world that we can convince
ourselves that we've solved important
problems no my goal isn't it chemistry
to work on robots of course my goal is
to kind of tell you a little bit about
some of the problems that we ran into
when we actually try to develop machine
learning algorithms that can try to
actually tackle some of the problems
that means so where's robot learning at
what in one example that I showed on the
previous slide that we've been able to
get a robot to do actually learning from
scratch in the real world from raw
pixels is enable a robot to use a
spatula to pick up an object and put it
into a bowl we were pretty excited about
this result maybe look at what looks a
little bit mundane for kind of the
average human this is actually something
that's really challenging to get a robot
to do
and there been a number of other
impressive works that have gotten robots
to do right very various things using
reinforcement learning algorithms and
while we are pretty excited to get these
sorts of things to work there's an issue
here and the issue is that the robot
didn't learn how to use spatulas to put
objects into containers but the robot
learned to put that spatula to use that
spatula to put that object into that
container if you gave it a different
spatula or a different object even a
different tablecloth the robot would
pail at the task and this isn't just
true for robot learning this is also
true for a broad range of reinforcement
learning problems as well they all learn
one task in a single environment
starting from scratch now you might say
well okay let's just give the robot more
spatulas more bowls more tablecloths and
it will generalize right and you would
be right they would be able to
generalize across a broader range of
environments a broader range of objects
but the challenges is that these
algorithms are not only learning from
scratch in these environments but they
also rely on detailed reward feedback
they rely on a human to reset the
environment and so even if you did want
to train them to be able to generalize
across those experiences they would
require a very substantial amount of
human involvement in order to learn
those skills and this is just an issue
with reinforced malaria in robotics it's
also an issue with with standard
supervised learning systems these
systems are trained on much more diverse
data sets if they're still trained on
one task starting from scratch with
fairly detailed supervision and this
isn't to say that these systems aren't
impressive these are systems that are
remarkably impressive that have become
the top champion of go that had been
able to translate between languages and
they're also tremendously useful but
they're all what I would refer to as
specialists and though they're learning
one very narrow task and instead what
I'd like to talk about today is can be a
naval system tsukimi accumulate
experiences and to acquire
general-purpose priors from those
experiences in a way that enables them
to learn quickly and perform reasoning
and
okay so it turns out that humans are
actually pretty good at this
accumulating experience and and you
think doing that in a way that enables
them to learn quickly and in particular
I'd like to see how good you are at it
so I'm gonna be a little test I'm giving
you three training or sixty training
data points on the left and your goal is
to learn from this training data how to
classify the image on the right
so the first three images on the left
are painted by Brock the second three
images were painted by Cezanne and your
goal is to determine the painter of the
painting on the right okay raise your
hand if you think it is Cezanne and
raise your hand if you think it is
Brooke okay
I think I saw more usually the audience
is actually better than this so the
correct answer is actually the correct
answer is Brock here and you can see
that by looking at some of the edges on
I think that most of you got it right I
was biased and so he wasn't really
pretty good at this
it's right on time so um how do you do
this how were most of you able to
accomplish this task
um you haven't seen we you're only given
six data points for this task right and
you had to learn from those six data
points and the reason why you're able to
accomplish this is that you weren't
learning from scratch you had a breadth
of previous experience and you you
haven't probably haven't seen these
painters before you may have seen these
painters but you probably haven't these
seen these specific paintings before and
you were able to use your previous
experience from other paintings that
you've seen to recognize shapes or
recognize textures in order to solve
this problem
into art learning from scratch so now
let's think about how we can enable
machines to do something like this ah in
particular if we want a machine learning
system to be able to solve this sort of
task
it can't be learning completely from
scratch and so naturally Brezza so the
question is how can we incorporate
previous experience into machine
learning systems so you may answer this
question a bit differently depending on
what era you're in if it was a long time
ago you might say that okay with model
the image formation process and use that
to guide our decision-making maybe a
little bit later you look at the
geometry in the image we're look at the
syph features and the hogg features they
mentioned in order to make a decision
and then in a more modern time you might
try to fine tune from imagenet features
or don't do domain adaptation from other
painters and one of the things that you
might see here is that as we go from
from top to bottom this process of
incorporating priors and incorporating
previous experience and previous
knowledge into these systems goes from
having fewer human priors to more
data-driven writers and undoubtedly the
the methods on the bottom have been more
successful than the methods on the top
and so naturally we might ask well
what's next what is kind of the best way
to try to incorporate previous
experience in these systems
and in pretty clear what if we tried to
take any completely data-driven approach
and actually optimizer learned for
priors such that downstream learning is
effective and fast that's exactly what
I'm going to talk about today is can we
explicitly learn priors from previous
experience that enable us to perform
downstream learning very efficiently and
this is what is known as learning to
learn learning how to learn and learning
how to quickly adapt to new situations
okay um so as kind of a brief outline or
overview of what I want to talk about
first thing we give a bit of a primer on
my learning and what it can accomplish
in the context of robotics as well as in
the context of other domains then second
I'll talk about some of the challenges
and frontiers with this with these
methods so first let's look at an
example this is gonna be very similar to
the example that I showed it at the
beginning where your goal is to perform
a few shot image classifications
um so what this looks like is you want
to be able to do a five-way wanton image
classification task where you're given
one example of five different classes
and your goal is to classify new
examples as being among one of the five
classes on the left okay so this is
analogous to the setting that I showed
you before and what we want to do is we
want to be able to enable a machine to
use other images in order to solve this
view shot-- classification problem in
particular what we're going to do is
we're going to structure the data from
other image classes such that it matches
what it sees at test time and pretty
sorry we can sample other five classes
and structure it into a training data
set and a test data set and do this for
a wide range of other image classes and
train the networks such that after it
sees the training data set on the Left I
can even effectively make predictions
for the images on the right we do this
across a number of different training
classes learning how to learn from these
very small data sets such that at test
time when it's given five examples from
held-out classes it can effectively make
predictions
essentially trying to match training
time and test time okay and this is what
it looks like for image classification
but you could replace these these image
classification tasks shown as rows with
something like regression with language
generation with skill learning really
any machine learning problem where you
want to be able to learn from small
amounts of data by leveraging experience
on on other tasks that look the same
okay so this is generally how the
problem setup looks like and or an
example of the problem statement and
kind of lets out one but like a typical
metal learning problem looks like so
same supervised learning our goal is to
map from inputs X tau that's why you
might have some parametrize function
that we want to be able to not perform
this mapping we typically learn this
mapping from input output pairs XY pairs
now what Meadows supervised learning
looks like is instead of giving given an
input and give it an output our goal is
to produce a learning procedure produce
something that takes us and put a data
set and makes predictions about new data
points from that ISS and so now our goal
is to produce something that takes as
input a training dataset that has Kate
and put output pairs for a K shot
learning problem and it just data set it
also wants to be able to make
predictions about new data points so
it's gonna be also taking as input X
test and making a prediction for the
label corresponding to that okay so this
is our goal is to produce a function
that something that takes as input a
training data set and produces a and
input and produces an output and then
the way that you might go about learning
this is from a data set of data sets
where each of these data sets here will
have at least will have more than K data
points such that you can sample K to be
used for the train data set and at least
one to be used to measure generalization
and whether or not you actually learn
from that training data space that data
set in that generalizable way
because I would think that before there
was methylamine then it's test that we
get a new data sense and they will have
to learn the function that classifies
the new dataset not just the point right
so maybe I didn't quite convey this
correctly so what's shown in green is
essentially what you want it to be able
to do at test time so in supervised
learning at test time you're taking in
inputs and producing outputs Y and meta
learning at test time you're taking in a
data set and a new data point and you
want to be able to make predictions
about the new data point given your
training data just exactly okay right so
the each of these data set says has a
number of input output pairs so this is
kind of a fairly mechanistic view of
metal learning I'm one of the nice
things about this view is that it
reduces the problem of meta learning to
just designing this function f and
optimizing that function a separate
field the meta learning problem is one
of a more prompt more of a probabilistic
view on medal earning which can make it
easier not necessarily to kind of
implement and optimize these algorithms
but to gain conceptual intuition for
what's happening here so one way to do
supervised learning from a probabilistic
view point is as inference where our
goal is to infer a set of parameters
given a data set and if you take this
viewpoint on supervised learning
you can obviously look at medicine
provides learning as trying to infer a
set of parameters given a data set and a
prior theta and the meta training
process as optimizing the parameters of
that fly of that prior theta such that u
such that the updated parameters or the
inferred parameters for each task
perform well on a held out set of data
in supervised learning case to make IAT
assumptions about the sample
what kind of assumption goes here
yeah so the Assumption here is that the
tasks that are used in training time and
test time are iid are sampled from the
same distribution I'm not quite familiar
with that framework but we can talk
about it afterwards after that answer
your question yeah you know how do you
transfer learning rate under some
assumptions made on how these different
tasks look like in it you should be able
to generalize across right so if they
said if these tasks are completely
random path so there's no shared
structure then there's nothing that you
can leverage in order to learn more
quickly and so there needs to be
something that is shared among these
tasks such that you can learn quickly
fortunately in practice the real world
exhibits considerable structure and the
tasks that we care about in general for
these algorithms to learn also exhibits
considerable structure that can be
leveraged to enable learning from
smaller amounts of data go I mean the
goal is to predict where the maximum
likelihood is just maybe not great week
approach how to achieve so you're saying
yes so you're saying this is not really
the problem statement this is the
appropriate problem statement solution
yeah absolutely
yeah I agree with that and there could
be other solutions okay you quantify the
similarity between tests so that like
yeah yeah absolutely so that's something
that is remarkably hard to quantify I'm
only actually aware of one work that
yeah yeah there are certainly lots of
works actually and I am more more than
one work the yeah there are certainly
some works to do it that how to do it
I'm not really satisfied with any of the
approaches that I've seen and I think
that it's something that's intimately
tied with how how easy with the
optimization process itself basically
how easy it is to learn some of these
tasks from from data and based on
previous experience for other houses
basically the different models of
similarity between us and probably
there's no generic solution for any
notion of say how similar the task there
will be may be different solutions
okay great so um it's worth mentioning
that there have been a lot of approaches
to this kind of problem ranging from
things like Bayesian hierarchical
Bayesian models things like metric
learning approaches learning or
recurrent neural networks learning
optimizers metric learning approaches or
really many many other approaches for
learning priors from data sets of data
sets one apart I'd like to highlight
that has been relatively popular
recently is to use a recurrent neural
network to model this this function of
people are one of the reasons why I like
to highlight it is that it's quite
general and and in simple in some
regards so the way that it works is you
just take in your data points in your
training dataset feed that into your
neural network directly such as into a
recurrent neural network your favorite
transformer model whatever and also
passed in the test data point and
trained it to make the correct
predictions given the test data point
and the data set corresponding to that
house so this is quite simple and more
than really nice things about this
approaches it's very expressive so a
recurrent neural network can represent a
wide range of learning procedures it's
very general and because it's very
general you can apply it to a wide range
of problems such as supervised learning
as well as meta reinforcement learning
problems now the Dom types of this model
is that by nature of it being a kind of
a large recurrent neural network that's
very expressive it's it's also has
considerable complexity it has to learn
how to learn from these data points from
scratch without any structure built into
the network and as a result because it
has to learn how to learn from these
data points that are passed in and often
the meta training process itself
requires large amounts of data large
amounts of meta data sets in some regard
in order to learn in order to train
on the meta-learning problem yeah does
that mean there is a sequence that
you're feeding or Trinity or the
sequence doesn't matter or even matters
yeah so if you're using our current
neural network that is inherently
imposing some sort of order to your data
points in most of these problems there
is no inherent order to the data points
although one of the nice things is that
it's relatively straightforward to
extend these kinds of models to an
active learning setting for example
where you want to be where the order
actually does matter because you may
have received labels for some data
points but not others whereas other
models like attention based models do
not impose that order and oftentimes as
moles actually do better because they
aren't kind of imposing structural
assumptions on the data that that don't
exist if it's a minor point but these
these cells of the recurrent neural
network they are different for the first
three steps and in terms of the inputs
that they'll have taken the last cell is
taking only X tests yeah so typically
you would like input some sort of token
that indicates that it's it's asking for
the crunch
okay great
so looking at kind of the downside of
this approach we wanted to develop an
algorithm that incorporates more
structure into the procedure such that
it doesn't have such a complex task at
hand and so in particular we wanted to
build upon some of the successes of
other transfer learning approaches and a
particular one very successful approach
for transfer learning is that of fine
tuning where you train or pre train your
model on some data set and then
initialize with that data set to Train
on another data set to leverage kind of
the richness of that first data set and
so kind of the way this works as I
mentioned is you have some set of
pre-training parameters theta and you
run gradient descent on training data
for a new task and these pre trained
parameters might be something like
imagenet and the training data for your
new tasks may be more modestly sized
than something like image done and this
has been quite successful but it will
only go so far so if your trained data
set for your new task only has three
data points or six data points or even
that 20 data points it will still either
massively over fit to those to those few
data points or it won't move far enough
in order to adopt the task and so what
we wanted to be able to do is given
previous experience figure out how we
might get a better initialization point
than something like image that for
example people are what we can do is we
can I say that we want to be able to
just fine-tune a test time on our very
small data sets and optimize for a set
of pre train parameters such that
fine-tuning on small data sets is
successful after you lurk what does it
look like as here's our fine-tuning step
we can evaluate how well fine-tuning
does on held-out data from that task and
optimized for the initialization such
that fine-tune a is successful and we
can do this across all of the tasks in
the Mediterranean data set if you do
this you
final test when you optimizing the
training so it's not a new task the past
that you already use to optimize how so
for each of the so there's kind of a
distinction between train and tests and
meta training and meta tests so we
assume that we have some some set of
meditating tasks and for each of those
tasks we have data and we can kind of
take that data from each of those meta
training tasks and split it up into a
training set and the test set and then
after the Mediterranean process we're
given a new task and a training data for
a trained dataset for that task we don't
have access to any of that at test time
and we run fine tuning from there and so
there is a well-defined training and
test procedure and this is something
where we refer to this as test in the
sense that we are evaluating on held-out
data points but it's not actually the
held-out data point so for this task
that is not basically these two days
hence we need to be destroyed so you can
measure generalization but it's not the
meta test set basically not the held out
tasks that we're going to be evaluating
on
theta is what we're optimizing for in
this case so actually optimizing for
initialization such that we can fine
tune effectively with small amounts of
data
yeah so in in practice we can use more
than one gradient update and we we often
do typically we actually find that one
to five gradient stops is is quite
effective you could also use more
depending on your computation in memory
about it but you optimize for one oh we
can optimize for more than one as well
so we often we optimize you won't
generally want to optimize for what
you'll be running at test time and we
write down one gradients up here for
notational convenience but you know it's
straightforward to do more great at sex
is something you have to play with when
you use this I also worry that you have
to tune the alpha each one is long yeah
so the main thing to tune here is alpha
and the number of inner gradient steps
in practice the their rails they're
relatively straightforward to tune other
works have found that you can actually
learn alpha in this optimization and
that works quite well as well if you
don't want to do any tuning you can just
just set the number of gradient stops to
be relatively large and and learn alpha
and
yeah different numbers of gradient steps
generalized to each other well there
that's a good question so we found that
if we actually train for one inner
gradient stop I become I guess basically
that it generalizes well for four more
gradient steps than what you trained for
the if you train for five gradients up
to the test on only one gradient step
and that isn't quite as effective
because it was trained for it to have
more gradient steps yeah yeah what about
the choice of sensation algorithms so it
has many other parameters
yeah so you could embed other
optimization procedures into this
optimization as well
one thing to note is that this this
optimization itself doesn't involve
second order terms and if you try to
also put a second order optimizer inside
here then you get third order terms we
yeah you can consider those things we
also actually have a new algorithm that
actually well we have a new algorithm
that actually allows you to embed things
like second order optimizations inside
the process without requiring a third
order optimization and if you're
interested in that I can talk to you
about it afterwards as well how do you
like this yeah so we optimized it with
gradient based algorithms so I got say
gradient descent Adam your favorite
optimizer and as I mentioned it does
involve second order terms but in
practice modern deep learning libraries
can handle it for you and it doesn't
involve anything more than like have
some vector products so it's something
that's both practical to implement and
not not often not too slow
to be inverted how much stencil duty to
get a table has to me for
like gradient descent how many tasks or
how many yeah um
in practice the the the mini batch size
for the number of pasts Ami's quite
small like four tasks eight tasks yeah
for these possible um for classification
problems we've we've worked with
cross-entropy loss just standard loss
functions
yeah we can company's loss function as
in the you over by Trevor you take about
yes there are a second order terms there
is yes
okay so I kind of the key idea here is
to learn a parameter vector that can
transfer effectively via fine tuning and
visually I guess given that you have
play of time to think about this and
maybe you already get some of the
intuition but some intuition for what's
happening here is we could be safe theta
is the parameter vector that's being
medal earned and Phi I star is the
optimal parameter vector for each task
that we can kind of intuitively view the
Mediterranean process as the cyclic line
where at this point during meditating we
take a gradient step with respect to
test three we're quite far from the
optimum for toss three and at the end of
the medal learning process if you take a
green step with respect to toss three
we're quite close to the optimum and
likewise for a number of other tasks
great so we refer to this procedure as
model agnostic medal learning in the
sense that it's agnostic to the model
that you use and the loss function that
you use as long as both of them are
amenable to create an based optimization
okay so to give a bit more intuition
here we can view it a brace view a very
simple reinforcement learning problem
where there's only gonna be two tasks
one is to run forward and one is to run
backward we aren't going to be testing
generalization in any way in this house
and so first model visualize is the
policy that learned after the meta
training process but before it takes any
adaptation step towards any particular
task and what we see is that it learns a
policy that simply runs in place at so
it's kind of ready to run in either
direction and if we take a single
gradient step with respect to the task
of running backward we get a policy that
looks like this and if we take a single
gradient step with respect at the task
of running forward we get a policy that
looks like this and so we'll just kind
of illustrate is that even with a single
grade and stuff you can substantially
change the behavior of the neural
network policy
okay so then I've given some intuitions
for these methods I like to give a
couple examples of what we can actually
do with these algorithms and more
interesting and complex situations so
first I will look at a situation where
we want to be able to leverage data from
previous environments in order to very
quickly adapt to a new environment so in
this case we're going to be looking at
these six legged robots here that are
shown on the left and we're gonna
collect data across a number of
different trains and train for an
initial model such that with a very
small amount of data actually just
milliseconds of data on that terrain it
can very quickly learn a dynamics model
of that environment and then what we're
gonna do is we're going to then take
that model want to adapt to a new
situation in this situation it's
actually be somewhat extrapolated from
what it saw during the meta training
process we're gonna take off the front
right leg of the robot and it's got its
goals gonna be able to run in a straight
line and so what it's doing is in only
kind of milliseconds of experience it
can figure out a model of this new
dynamics that is in and use that model
in order to plan to follow with a
straight line whereas in comparison if
you instead didn't adopt the model or
adapted it but didn't actually train for
the model to be adopted it ends up
veering off to the right instead of
actually following a straight line okay
now one more example setting this is
another setting in robotics where we
wanted to be able to leverage experience
with previous objects in order to
generalize or adopt to a new object the
robot has never seen before so in this
case we collected demonstration data for
placing objects into containers and we
we collected that across a wide range of
training objects and then we at test
time gave it the demonstration for
placing an object into a new container
where I've never seen the object or any
of the containers before and the robot
can figure out a policy that maps from
the images from its camera to the
control
the end-effector controls of the robot
and figure out how to solve this house
we can also take this one step further
and collect demonstration data as well
as human video data for objects and
train it such that after it sees a video
of a human I can use that that data to
figure out a policy that can perform the
task that was demonstrated by the human
all right so these are some examples of
what we can do with meta learning in
robotics and the ideas that I mentioned
are not just specific to robotics of
course so we've also seen systems that
can leverage previous language
experience to quickly learn how to
translate between two languages where
you don't have a lot of data between
those languages leverage previous
segmentation experience where you want
to learn how to segment images with only
a few pixel labels leverage experience
across domains to quickly transfer
between different domains experience
with previous objects for generating new
objects and new viewpoints of objects as
well as personalization to new human
users to be able to adapt to those users
these work these these are some example
applications there are many many others
these are just some that that I chose to
highlight here okay great so there were
a bit more questions than I was
expecting I think I have about 15 more
minutes the know they talked a bit about
kind of some of these algorithms it
actually worked quite well I like to
talk about some of the challenges in the
problem statement so there are a couple
things that I think the problem
statement that don't quite exhibit the
kinds of things that we care about in
real-world settings the first is that
previous experience doesn't always come
all at once in order to perform meta
training on and I'll talk a bit about
how we can handle that setting and
lastly there are also situations where
you don't know what the tasks should be
or where the tests should come from and
if I have some time I'll talk about that
as well but first let's talk about
experience coming all at once so so far
I've shown kind of given in the iid
tasks distribution you want to be able
to learn a new task efficiently but more
realistically in the real world agents
may not have a large batch of tasks
right off the bat instead they may see
one task at a time and hence kind of a
more realistic embodiment of the meta
learning
problem is one where the tasks are
presented in an online and streaming
fashion and at the beginning the agents
may learn slowly Kenda learning from
scratch because they don't have previous
experience but after they accumulate
experience with these tasks we want them
to learn both become faster at learning
each new thing as well as better at
learning each David okay so how might we
try to formalize this problem well one
place of inspiration that we could get
for this problem is that of online
learning where an agent is house was
performing a sequence of tasks right
however this problem setting better is
an agent's ability to perform new tasks
and zero shop and so if our goal is to
learn it like he'd be able to handle a
new situation in zero shot I mean that
may not even be possible in some
situations and so instead we wanted to
develop a problem setting that actually
captures this notion of being able to
accelerate learning over time this is
what we called the online medal learning
setting where the goal isn't to perform
a sequence of tasks and zero shot but be
able to evaluate performance after
seeing a small amount of data on each
task in sequence so in particular what
this problem setting looks like as first
we have kind of a sequence of rounds as
in online learning then the world picks
some loss function this corresponds to a
task at that round then the agent needs
to pick some some parameter vector theta
without any knowledge of the loss
function of the current time step and
then he gets access to some update
procedure that it can use to adapt to
the current task at that round and this
update procedure could be something like
a step of gradient descent or a few
steps are granted descent on some data
for that task then after performing that
update procedure the agent is evaluated
on the updated parameters theta tilde on
that task
okay so this is what the problem site
looks like and our goal is to be able to
look get an algorithm that has sub
linear regret because the whole success
of transfer learning is because
similarity of presents and regret is the
worst case scenario well you're doing
badly but you trust that the competitor
also think that it's a completely
different set up and story so in this
case the TAS may not be chosen
adversarially is that what you're asking
they regret the regret is just saying
over all possible their choices I don't
care if I fail as long as my competitor
face this way it's really working
only when the tasks are very similar so
it's kind of different
I agree though it's a different
framework I do think that some of the
ideas from transfer learning are very
interesting in this setting and I think
that there is something to be gained
from kind of merging these frameworks
and summer we could it be that when the
passes and learn the benchmarking was
right Mariela right in one direction
student you can do
then they passed when that's the signal
is much easier than and the real
question is what is the similarity
between the tests prepared against worst
case it's the same thing let's see how
she what I don't get is what is it
different than the online read all aware
you compound LT with SIA T and then say
yes so if the update if there's no
update procedure it is exactly the
classical all my learning problem what's
different is that you get access to this
update procedure I mean in this update
procedure you could be given for example
a small amount of data that allows you
to adapt to the task of the current
route
and so in this case what the regret
looks like is the loss achieved by your
algorithm compared to the loss of the
best bet already algorithm in hindsight
yes update procedure just part to
finding your meta learning algorithm is
it in the midterm that's like this what
does this mean yeah this is the the
update procedure performed on your
you're chosen from the record if you use
that update engineer on some best chosen
parameter yes Kevin
dippity-doo is constant across both the
comparator class enemy yes
and that's consistent with what you can
do before right yes so in this work we
studied basically the how we can extend
the follow-the-leader algorithm but with
metal learning essentially so you can
essentially optimize for performance
after performing this update procedure
is essentially the man will algorithm on
all the tasks up until time step T and
what we show in this work is that
informally if your if your loss function
is second-order smooth and strongly
convex then the regret grows logarithmic
in T you're smiling yeah okay it only
grows logarithmically in teeth which is
great which means that we're actually
doing something that's essentially
non-trivial and and asymptoting to zero
as we see more and more these receive
whereas transfer learning this goes to
zero as you have more and more tasks
yeah maybe the division maybe there is a
division by TLC average but they're not
talking about the average of all tasks
we're talking about performance in the
last class so before the last class here
grows we steal and we transfer them it
goes to zero as you have more training
so it's not necessarily like the last
deviance
yeah but what the Sun grows is there's
more he's not scalable to some you care
for the last time how fast you're going
to do it you don't care about the Sun
and for the last you ask why do I
succeed though the residual breath of
also consider all of the some otherwise
the adversary can just transfer Danny is
an assumption of similarity it's just 50
doesn't appear in the theory so what you
can get you can get a regret bound for
non-convex I'm sorry good good point so
this is in the case where your update
procedure is one great into sub stuff
okay
okay so beyond the theoretical results
we also actually try to practically
instantiate this which essentially
corresponds to meta training with mammal
on all the data so far and fine tuning
on the current house and we experiment
with sequences of pests in this case the
tasks are not chosen adversarial
adversarially and we experimented with
things like colored rotated and scaled
m-miss 3d object pose friction tasks
where your goal is to predict the pose
of different objects in sequence as well
as see far 100 classification where I
introduced new classes over time and we
compared to a number of different quite
strong base lines in some regard from
the online learning literature well this
one's not necessarily from the online
learning literature but the next one
will be so in this case this base line
is simply just a train on all the data
that you've seen so far train a single
network to be able to pick the pose of
all of the objects to be able to pick
the the identity of all the Emmis digits
etcetera the second is something that
corresponds roughly to follow leader
where you train on all the data so far
and then fine-tune on the current task
and then the last one corresponds to
training on each toss that you see from
scratch and what we see is we're to be
measuring both data efficiency as you
see new tasks as well as learning
proficiency as you see each new task
absolutely be measured in terms of the
number of data points to achieve a
certain level of proficiency as well as
the error on each task after seeing a
fixed number of data points and so what
we show here kind of first overall trend
is that everything is going down as we
expect the performance is getting better
as you see more tasks
Tranio and everything improves over time
we see this downward trend but is prone
to negative transfer which we can see by
the fact that is actually doing worse
than the red line in some cases was
doing worse than training on all on
tasks from scratch the second approach
is able to follow the leader is able to
achieve consistent forward transfer and
also we also see this trend but
sometimes it over fits
so on on the rainbow I'm gonna studying
we see that it's able to outperform
training on everything by the fact that
it can adapt to the current task but in
the post friction case we see that it
tends to over fit with that data whereas
if we're actually met a training such
that we can quickly adapt to these tasks
and adapting to each of these tasks in
sequence we see that I can learn each
new task faster and with greater
proficiency and by the end of training
can actually approach the few shot
learning regime where it only requires a
few data points to adopt to a new house
and by the end we would hope that if we
extended this wide outward it would be
able to be able to kind of reach the
zero shot by immersion as well okay I
don't think I have time for we're
talking about that where we can get
tasks from given all of the questions so
to kind of sum up I talked about how
meddling provides a way to optimize for
priors that lead to few felt learning
how we concidered this study and how we
can study these types of algorithms in
the online setting where we're given
tasks in sequence and I didn't have time
to cover how we can actually try to
propose tasks from from unlabeled
experience and I think that both of
these bring us closer towards or
realistic lifelong learning settings
where we're accumulating experience over
time and using that experience to
quickly learn new tasks and then one new
thing I'd like to pitch for people that
work on reinforcement learning another
interesting question that I think is
really important is meta learning across
distinct class families and we have a
benchmark coming out where we already
created 50 distinct manipulation tasks
where to have a shared workspace a
common Thaksin space and that we
designed for studying these kinds of
problems in multi tossed transfer and in
meta learning great so I'd like to thank
my collaborators and students and if we
have time I'd be happy to take a few
more questions thank you
[Applause]
questions
who's everyone over there yeah
so I glanced over this paper and it
seems like in it you extend like the
comparator class to being able to
fine-tune on each task and and the
theorem that lets you like transfer the
results just I was wondering can you
provide any intuition about like
standing the comparator class till I
also be able to do gradient update just
like still let you transfer the results
it seems like the classes bigger yeah so
what we have to show is that the
comparator classes convex in that's kind
of the the most tricky thing about it
and we show that in the paper and I
guess the other interesting thing is
that the assumptions that we make to
show that don't completely trivialize
the medal learning study which means
that it is actually somewhat useful in
an entrepreneurial Network settings
okay how do you handle the order of the
tests any experiments in the theory
anything so that can not be learned
without learning other paths first yeah
so we assume that the task order is
provided if you I mean it would be
interesting to study the setting we
actually get to choose which task you
study next we didn't study that in this
work if you if it's not possible to
learn a task given kind of the previous
experience then in theory what the
problem setting will do is you'll just
achieve high error for that task and
then you'll move on to the next one in
practice one thing that you can do is if
you have you can well they didn't really
study that much in this work but you can
basically allow the algorithm to decide
how many data points at once and this is
actually fairly easy to do if you by
just measuring validation error like
holding out some of the data that you've
seen so far if you have low validation
error then you could app then you can
say okay I'm done with this task I
should move on to the next one versus
continuing to accumulate accumulate data
and given enough data for one task it
should be possible to to learn that
house I need to visualize how that
transfer for example if you want to have
a human learn to bike before there's the
what yeah so when the reinforcement
learning setting I almost covered this
in my in in my kind of future work
slides and the reinforcement resetting
exploration actually becomes a really
interesting problem in medal learning
because it's not just about learning
from data but it's also about going
about how you collect that data as well
and that affects learning and in a very
huge way and exploration and there
there's a number of interesting things
on the algorithmic side in terms of the
yeah I think that in terms of kind of
the lifelong mental learning setting
where you apply that in a reinforcement
learning setting we haven't looked at
the reinforcement learning setting yet I
think that it might be noon in terms of
like future work in that direction I
think that we would want to actually
just assume that a human gives us that
at least is a fur
step just as how we don't put our babies
on bikes before they learn how to walk
the reason doesn't seem like a term that
Blake pre-plea guarantee that you're not
gonna forget about the house you see you
have seen before right so in this case
we assume that we could store all the
data for the previous tasks and could
train on that data for the tasks that we
showed even though we were considering
sequences of up to a hundred tasks we
didn't observe any significant burden on
the memory night or on the computational
side from storing the data and in
reinforcement learning a very common
practice to store extremely large data
sets and without observing problems with
regard to kind of recalling data a
smooth apron the question is opera an
interest of time so that concludes our
talks for today tomorrow I'm gonna get a
lot more into a reinforcement learning
I'm just going to be now a reception
outside and I just thank all the
speakers again